nous sommes à une heure de Madrid dans
la Finka le péché mortel propriété de
manuels
sa famille élève des taureaux de combat
depuis 1860
à l'élevage de taureaux de combat
nous avons de bons pâturages un climat
propice ni trop froid en hiver ni trop
chaud en été
contrairement au reste de l'Espagne
c'est vraiment un privilège
ils ne sont plus que 1200 éleveurs en
Espagne à perpétuer cette tradition
chacun de ces taureaux sera élevé en
liberté pendant quatre ans avant de
mourir dans l'arène
je vais leur donner à manger un petit
peu
[Musique]
manuel possède 200 têtes de bétail il
connaît chacun de ses animaux par leur
nom elle
couleado un peu plus loin là-bas
le châtain là il va participer à une
corrida de taureau parce qu'il a des
cornes bien écartées
exclusivement pour le spectacle et ce
spectacle génère beaucoup d'argent et
d'emplois et ça les défenseurs des
animaux ne le comprennent pas
dans deux semaines manuel va livrer
trois de ces taureaux pour une corrida
chaque bête lui rapportera près de 4000
euros
[Musique]
les spectacles torins génèrent chaque
année près de 4 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires mais en disant face à
la pression des antitorins à la crise
économique et au covid le nombre des
corridas a diminué d'un tiers en Espagne
mettant en péril cette activité qui fait
vivre 200000 personnes
pour Manuel l'élevage de taureaux de
combat est de moins en moins rentable
mais il ne peut se résoudre à abandonner
sa passion
le tour est rose c'est une star comme à
Hollywood même mieux qu'à Hollywood car
les acteurs comparé à lui ils font pas
grand chose
d'art avec une bête sauvage quand il est
dans la reine et fait certains
mouvements pour moi il crée un
chef-d'oeuvre et c'est de la culture
notre culture même si certains disent le
contraire c'est de l'art ou même titre
que le travail d'un peintre la
profession de torero c'est un art et à
ce titre il faut la respecter
un art qui attire encore des passionnés
de toute l'Europe
ce matin c'est un groupe de nîmois qui
vient visiter la propriété de manuel
je vais vous emmener voir les vaches
dans les champs et puis après les jeunes
taureaux
[Musique]
et ensuite il y a Fernando Adrian qui
doit venir et on va faire une bâche ou
deux on va voir
c'est touriste parcourent l'Espagne
depuis une semaine et visite les lieux
emblématiques de la tauromachie
Isabelle vigne et la présidente de
l'association
qui a pas son foulard c'est le plus
vieux club Torin de France
ses membres se retrouvent pour faire
vivre la fissionne la passion du Taureau
alors nous sommes
150 personnes voilà
il y a pas de problème de recrutement
en si comme partout
comme partout nous sommes nous sommes
vieillissants dans la fission donc si
beaucoup de jeunes pouvaient rentrer ce
serait ce serait bien
un recrutement qui s'avère difficile
84% des jeunes Espagnols se déclarent
antitorin
[Musique]
ce clash des générations se retrouve
dans le public des arènes
vieillissant et de plus en plus
clairsemés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui manuel organise une corrida
privée pour le club nîmois
pour l'occasion il a fait venir un jeune
torero prometteur
Fernando Adrian a 30 ans et combat
depuis une décennie
papa tu peux fermer la porte s'il te
plaît
[Musique]
je me sens bien pas de stress
particulier
[Musique]
Fernando va affronter deux jeunes
taureaux
des novillots de 200 kg
pour lui c'est un entraînement
il n'y aura aucune mise à mort
mais le risque est toujours présent
Fernando se déplace gratuitement pour
participer à ses corridas c'est sa
manière de militer et de convaincre les
sceptiques
bien sûr j'ai des amis qui n'aiment pas
la corrida ou qui ne la connaissent pas
mais quand ils m'ont vu combattre dans
de grandes arènes ils ont pu se faire
leur propre opinion
et se rendre compte du danger que
représente le taureau
mais aussi de l'émotion que procure une
corrida quand tout se déroule bien
[Musique]
en Espagne le clivage n'est pas
uniquement générationnel il est aussi
politique
les parties de gauche s'opposent
majoritairement la tauromachie alors que
la droite veut préserver cette tradition
Madrid est emblématique de ce combat
en 2016 la coalition de gauche au
pouvoir supprime les subventions la
tauromachie et signe l'arrêt de mort
d'un lieu mythique le Batan
a fermé ce lieu et l'école taurine a dû
mettre la clé sous la porte
et le chorale est resté à l'abandon
comme vous pouvez le voir
surtout l'école qui a toujours existé
ici
c'est un lieu historique et le voir dans
cet état ça fait mal au cœur
avec le retour de la droite au pouvoir à
Madrid il y a deux ans l'école a rouvert
ses portes
bonjour
elle forme depuis un demi-siècle les
meilleurs toreros du pays
Guillermo Garcia est l'un d'entre eux
il est professionnel depuis l'âge de 18
ans
voilà
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d'autre profession où l'on
risque sa vie de cette manière là
enfin plus qu'une profession un art ou
l'artiste met sa vie en jeu c'est pour
ça qu'il y a une connotation si
particulière
car le torero risque sa vie à chaque
instant et c'est là que réside la
spécificité et la difficulté de la
tauromachine et la la
Guillermo est finaliste du grand tournoi
de la région de Madrid
s'il gagne
ce sera la consécration de cette année
d'efforts
alors pour réussir il s'entraîne
quotidiennement aux côtés d'Augustine
Serrano un torero de 59 ans
à ce stade de leur carrière voilà aucun
de ses professionnels ne vide son art
j'ai dû concilier ma carrière de torero
avec un deuxième métier
je suis chauffeur de formation je
conduis un taxi depuis de nombreuses
années j'ai toujours dû faire ça
Guillermo lui a l'ambition d'en vivre et
de devenir matador la reconnaissance
suprême pour un torero
ils ne sont plus que 460 à détenir ce
titre en Espagne
un tiers de moins qu'il y a 8 ans
alors chaque weekend il retrouve sa
famille pour commenter ses corridas
bonjour Guillaume
tu vas bien
tous partagent cette passion et sont
conscients des risques qu'ils courent
[Musique]
ça c'est la deuxième bête celle qui
courait beaucoup
[Musique]
je suis très fière de lui
dans cette corrida il s'en est bien
sorti et ça me procure beaucoup de
bonheur
mais quand je le vois je suis angoissée
j'ai peur
mon corps est tétanisé
je suis désorienté
je veux juste que ça se termine quand ça
se passe mal je suis effondré et même si
tout va bien j'imagine que le pire peut
encore arriver je veux juste que ça se
termine
l'embrasser et qu'il rentre à la maison
Guillermo n'a jamais été blessé il a
affronté son premier taureau à l'âge de
13 ans
pour lui la mort de l'animal fait partie
d'un rituel immuable et chaque arme à
son usage
là ce sont toutes les armes que
j'utilise pour tuer
ici ce sont mes épées je vais vous les
sortir
ce sont celles qui me portent chance
pour la mise à mort
pas à tuer le taureau
on l'appelle le bourreau c'est pour
abréger ses souffrances
une sentence qu'il applique sans faillir
ne souffre quasiment pas
quand il arrive dans la reine
son instinct de survie est précédé par
une poussée d'arzonaline
et avec l'adrénaline il va se défendre
lutter pour sa vie
il n'a pas le temps de penser à la
douleur des coups d'épée
quand l'animal meurt il meurt en
combattant
il fait abstraction de la douleur quand
il est dans une arène ce n'est pas comme
les autres animaux que l'on tue dans un
abattoir
[Musique]
la souffrance des taureaux est souvent
niée ou minimisée par les partisans de
la corrida y compris par des
vétérinaires proches du milieu torrent
pour rectifier cette vision procès
Enrique Saldivar a créé en 1998
l'association des vétérinaires pour
l'abolition de la tauromachie
voilà c'est le magazine où a été publié
l'étude
c'est juste du bon sens
comment peut-on imaginer qu'un animal
qui subit toutes ses souffrances de
sentent rien il faudrait qu'il soit en
pierre
l'association de rosaines Riquet
Saldivar regroupe 400 vétérinaires qui
enquêtes et informe le grand public sur
la réalité de la tauromachie
tout ça ce sont les différents
instruments
les armes comme il les appelle
qui sont utilisés pendant les combats
[Musique]
les armes ont pour but d'émousser
l'agressivité du taureau
réduisons ainsi les risques pour le
torero mais les blessures causées à
l'animal sont extrêmement violentes
utilise cet arbre qui s'appelle la
pouilla la pique
elle déchire les muscles les tendons les
ligaments
qui mesure 6 cm de longueur et qui vont
endommager de nouveaux des muscles et
des vaisseaux sanguins
on appelle ça un vivador pourquoi ce
terme est bien comme le taureau est
sorti très affaibli physiquement du
premier acte la manière de le réveiller
c'est de raviver la douleur
et comment
passons à la mise à mort le torero va
utiliser les stocks c'est une épée qui
mesure 80 cm de longueur
et quand elle rentre d'un seul coup
elle provoque une hémorragie massive et
une mort entre guillemets propre du
taureau
du temps selon les statistiques taurines
et selon les chiffres de notre
association seul 13 à 14% des mises à
mort se passe comme prévu
ces campagnes de sensibilisation portent
leurs fruits
les Espagnols sont de plus en plus
critiques envers la corrida
le parti animaliste pacma milite depuis
20 ans pour interdire la tauromachie
pour asphyxier cette activité
ces membres réclament la suppression des
subventions publiques
cette année les administrations ont
dépensé énormément d'argent pour la
tauromachie tout ce qui n'a pas été
utilisé pendant la pandémie ils l'ont
dépensé et c'est indignait beaucoup de
gens car cet argent aurait pu aller à
d'autres dépenses indispensables plutôt
que corrida je crois que les gens vont
prendre leur courage à deux mains et
venir manifester
chaque année au mois de septembre les
associations antitorine organisent une
grande manifestation pour sensibiliser
la population
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
océanrique ses collègues vétérinaires
font partie du cortège
[Applaudissements]
une partie de la population est
indifférente à la souffrance de l'animal
dans ce business de la tauromachie
et le moyen d'augmenter notre influence
pour lutter contre ce milieu c'est
d'arriver à mobiliser le plus de monde
possible et que les gens nous écoutent
et nous appuient
[Musique]
pour se faire entendre les 2000
manifestants ont choisi de se réunir au
pied des arènes de Madrid le temple de
la tauromachie en Espagne
depuis 15 ans les antitorins ne cessent
de scander le même message abolition
totale
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes patients même si on sait que
le temps presse pour ses animaux et cela
nous affecte beaucoup
mais je n'ai aucun doute que ça va se
terminer même le monde du taureau c'est
que la fin est proche les grandes arènes
cette année ont eu un taux d'occupation
très bas on sait que ça va se terminer
mais vous dire quand je ne sais pas
[Musique]
chaque année ce sont 70 000 euros qui
sont sacrifiés dans les fêtes taurines
alors les manifestants ont un but faire
tomber une à une les grandes arènes du
pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le Bing porte ses fruits
125 communes espagnoles ont supprimé les
factories parmi elles Barcelone la
deuxième ville du pays
l'une des arènes a été convertie en
centre commercial
et la plus célèbre la monommentale
accueille désormais des spectacles et
des concerts
Enrique Guilhem ancienne star de la
tauromachie catalane n'en revient
toujours pas
là
pour mon accession au grade de matador
et là ma dernière corrida dans cette
arène de Barcelone
ce sont beaucoup de souvenirs et de
nostalgie et j'aurais aimé que ça
continue
interdire la corrida c'est pour les
indépendantistes catalans rejetaient les
valeurs de l'Espagne en 2010 leur
alliance avec le mouvement antitorin a
permis de voter un décret qui a mis fin
à la tauromachie dans la région
c'était un thème 100 % politique ça a
été la première pierre de
l'indépendantisme catalan ils ont
utilisé notre culture et notre mode de
vie et ils ont réussi à manipuler la
population contre nous en leur faisant
croire que c'était un thème animaliste
alors que c'était un enjeu
indépendantiste et politique
Enrique ne savoure pas vaincu
il a décidé d'enseigner son art dans
l'unique école de tauromachie de
Catalogne
puisque les arènes sont fermées
c'est en bordure d'un stade de football
dans la banlieue de Barcelone qui
l'entraîne une poignée d'irréductible
là on a un chariot en forme de taureau
et des cornes pour mimer les charges
c'est tout l'équipement de l'école
à l'ombre de ces tours l'école Touring
de Barcelone accueille une dizaine
d'élèves pendant l'année
Mario Hugo et Alba sont les plus assidus
tu de famille amateurs de corrida ils
vivent mal de strassisme qui frappe leur
activité
c'est vrai que depuis qu'ils ont
interdit les corridas je me sens un peu
seul comme si j'avais été marginalisé
mais je suis quand même fier car à
l'époque actuelle il faut de la
personnalité pour être torero
depuis un mois c'est le jeune qui les a
rejoint sa préoccupation n'est pas
d'ordre politique mais plutôt technique
tu dois faire l'effort d'utiliser cette
moule état c'est vrai qu'elle est grande
plus grande que toi
allez entraîne-toi
c'est notre dernière recrue mais le
gamin a une envie et quelque chose de
spécial
allez on recommence
même si les fier de son statut
d'apprentitorero enrelle a encore du mal
à l'assumer en public
peut-être que je le ferai dans le futur
omachie
[Musique]
la bataille de l'opinion publique semble
définitivement perdue dans les grandes
villes c'est sans doute le clivage le
plus prononcé ville contre campagne
est un village de 8000 habitants à une
heure de Madrid
il a deux fiertés son château médiéval
et ses arènes
cette année il accueille la finale de la
Coupe Chanel qui désignera le meilleur
torero de la province
Paloma Moreno et l'une des
organisatrices du festival
on va monter la tente au cas où
cette année la municipalité de San
Martin des valves s'est fixé un objectif
séduire un jeune public
[Musique]
bon tu vas avoir un petit peu chaud
la jeunesse
d'ailleurs on va faire un atelier de
fabrication de banderies et un atelier
de corrida au final il faut encourager
cette passion depuis le plus jeune âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis 2013 la corrida figure au
patrimoine culturel de l'Espagne et à ce
titre elle perçoit 25 millions d'euros
de subventions annuelle
une aide indispensable à l'organisation
de fête taurine
mais pour le village de San Martin des
vallées Iglesias organisé une corrida
reste un sacrifice financier
il y a énormément de dépenses et ici
dans les régions du Nord on a beaucoup
de difficultés à obtenir des aides de la
part de l'administration ils font en
sorte que tout soit beaucoup plus
compliqué mais on doit résister se
développer lutter parce que nous sommes
la base de la tauromachie et si on
investit pas dans le futur dans quelques
années on le regrettera mais j'espère
que ce ne sera pas le cas
la corrida débute dans cette heure mais
déjà dans les coulisses c'est
l'effervescence
nous retrouvons manuel Sands l'éleveur
découvre les arènes où vont combattre
ses bêtes
c'est un moment difficile j'ai les nerfs
à vif
je me sens mal le jour de la corrida
jusqu'à ce que sorte mon premier taureau
je suis vraiment stressé
c'est l'honneur de manuel et de son
élevage qui sont en jeu
s'il est heureux ne sont pas assez
combatifs le public le sifflera
alors chaque bête doit être examinée
c'est un moment crucial pour manuel
fait sortir le taureau allez ouvre la
porte
[Musique]
ils identifient chaque jeune taureau et
ils vont juger s'ils peuvent combattre
s'ils sont en forme et s'ils se
déplacent bien
les taureaux sont ensuite enfermés dans
des box pendant plusieurs heures pour
décupler leur peur et leur agressivité
à quelques pas des arènes Guillermo
Garcia est fin prêt
il a revêtu son habit de lumière
bonne chance
bonne chance à toi
[Musique]
en ce dimanche il ne reste que deux
quadrilles de torero en lice pour la
finale
pendant une heure Guillermo va affronter
trois taureaux de l'élevage de manuels
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
saignée par la lance du picador
et des coups de banderilles
le taureau s'épuise devant les passes de
Guillermo
[Applaudissements]
après 20 minutes de combat c'est le coup
de grâce dans des arènes à moitié vide
un public dégarni témoin impuissant de
la perte de vitesse de la tauromachie en
Espagne
[Applaudissements]